wow that actually suggests a lot of
shocking
revelations for book three
and uh
i'm so sorry i think i'm having mic
problems i'll be right right back
thoughts on philip k dick's work i think
everybody you know
loves dick okay
if you don't love dick it's probably
that you've never really tried dick
sorry or maybe you tried some dick and
it just really wasn't
good dick oh that that's not that i
don't in my opinion if you
try some dick and it wasn't really for
you you really need to think was i in
the right headspace for this
oh george r.r martin is here that's uh
awesome actually could we maybe finish
our chat later uh pat try try some
different dick let's
stop this you know some of it's a little
more experimental dick or some of it's a
little more surreal some of it's kind of
rough okay you want that i don't care
about that do it deck isn't for everyone
exactly right it's not it's not for
everybody it's not for everybody
um so we were talking about book three
but you know there's there's a lot of
people who really enjoy deck
[Music]
[Music]
you